18% des personnes handicapées sont au
chômage
c'est près de deux fois plus que le
reste de la population active
pourtant dès les années 40 des campagnes
de sensibilisation était diffusé à la
télévision avec un message les
handicapés peuvent travailler
est-ce que je peux regarder ce crochet
vous pensez aux péris avec ça j'y
arriverai bien à l'école il est
difficile de faire fonctionner cette
personne sans les deux mains je vous
assure que je peux réussir il faudra
attendre 1987 pour que le gouvernement
mène une politique en faveur de l'emploi
des personnes handicapées
une loi impose aux entreprises de plus
de 20 salariés d'embaucher 6 % de
travailleurs handicapés
mais malgré ces mesures l'emploi reste
encore éloigné et aux chefs d'entreprise
finalement qui rechignent à embaucher
des personnes handicapées
qu'est ce que vous auriez envie de dire
essayer c'est l'adopter
non mais qui nous donne au moins un
essai comme comme tout à chacun
et lorsque les travailleurs handicapés
trouver un emploi c'est bien souvent à
temps partiel
s'il concerne 18 % de l'ensemble des
salariés en france la proportion monte à
34 % pour les travailleurs handicapés
même différence au niveau des postes
occupés
si les cadres représentent 18% de
l'ensemble des salariés en france ces
sept pour cent des travailleurs
handicapés exemple en 2007 avec nicolas
thomass kovic diplômée de la sorbonne et
de sciences po il est donc
particulièrement aptes à accéder à des
postes de cadre supérieur pourtant
trouver du travail quand on est aveugle
relève aujourd'hui de l'exploit disons
qu'au début on est dans la situation du
chômeur classique on se dit que ben
le marché de l'emploi difficile pour
tout le monde mais au fur et à mesure
des refus des lettres on reçoit on se
dit que mon âme spécificité qui fait que
c'est encore plus difficile pour que
pour monsieur tout le monde c'est vers
la situation de handicap qui a une
double barrière à l'emploi l'égalité
n'est pas encore là sur le marché de
l'emploi
mais la situation progresse petit à
petit en 2006 60 % des entreprises
comptait au monde une personne
handicapée parmi ses salariés en 2014
c'était 78 % des entreprises
[Musique]